>>Eric: Welcome to the Android device manufacture
fireside chat. My name is Eric
Chu. I am responsible for many of the developer
initiative that some of you may
be familiar with. I'm also the moderator for
this session. So the goal of this
session really is provide a venue so that
our device manufacturer partners can
give you an overview about what they've been
doing with Android and where we've
been going and also give you opportunity to
ask questions on some of their great
Android products that they're making. So with
us on the far right with Bill
Maggs. He is the -- Sony Ericsson's head of
developer partner for North
America; next to him we have Ciaran Rochford,
he is Samsung's director of mobile
R&D group; we also Joon Kang, who is LG Electronics,
head of strategic alliance;
and then on the far left, we have Lori Fraleigh,
who is the -- who is Motorola's
director developer platform and services.
So the format of this session is
that each one of them is gonna spend about
five minutes to kind of talk about
what they've been doing with Android, why
Android's important, where they're
taking Android within the product portfolio,
and then when they're done, we'll
open the floor for questions. I'm also told
that I need to kinda let you know
that if you want to monitor live notes and
also answer questions in the wave
please go to http://bit.ly/waveio. With that,
why don't we start with Bill.
>>Bill: Hi, everybody. I've been having a
great time at this conference 'cause
it's pretty much the largest gathering that
we know about of strictly Android
developers, although there's obviously a lot
of you that are developing for more
than one platform. So I'll just talk for a
minutes about how Sony Ericsson sees
Android, the products that we're coming out
with and, you know, our hopes really
for this platform in the future. So we've
been working on it for some time. I
think we're an early adherent of going Android
in our product portfolio. As you
guys probably know, we've been a headset company
for a long time with -- present
in many markets making products based on a
lot of different kinds of software
platforms. But as our CEO has recently said,
Android is really going to be our
emphasis going forward 'cause we think that
it's really architected for the
future from a technical point of view and
also from -- hopefully from a business
point of view. It's got its own interesting
aspects to it and we are coming to
market in a big way in 2010. We take a certain
approach to doing products where
we try -- we think there are certain thing
that is we're good at that are in
line with our kind of identity and we've really
worked very hard to bring some
of those capabilities to our Android products,
working with Google along the way
and we'll continue to, to try and make the
platform work better and make really
the template for you, as developers, work
better, to give you more opportunities
to create things because we do fundamentally
believe that one of the things that
an Open Platform like Android gives is the
ability to put the information in
your hands that are gonna help to, you know,
really sell our products in the
future. So the products that we're bringing
to market in 2010 that kind of
reflect our approach to Android are ones -- the
first of them being our flag
ship, the X10, which is now shipping in the
world. It's the fastest selling
smartphone in the history of Japan. And so
Howard Stringer was talking some
smack earlier about that I guess, compared
to the iPhone. And it's coming to
market everywhere. One of the things that
I can say to you is that all of our
Android products are going to be coming out
just -- not just globally but also
in -- in the United States during 2010. The
X10 is a product that has a lot of
fantastic capabilities of things that people
thing Sony Ericsson's really good
at like imaging, multimedia, the idea of entertainment
and things we can do with
the device. So we've really started with a
strong -- the strong Android, you
know, base, and added things to it. For instance,
we have the capability of
doing face recognition and video scene recognition
right out of the camera
module. These are things that we're bringing
to market to really help the
handset be really great but we also want these
kinds of technologies to be
things that we share with you. So other products
that are now out and they're
going to be coming to this part of the world
as well as everywhere else you can
see in our developer -- our OEN sandbox downstairs
are of a very different form
factor than the X10 which is a big, beautiful,
four-inch device, 4M screen
device, which is another statement I wanna
make about Android. We're bringing
the X10 Mini and Mini Pro out and if you see
those products, they're really,
really taking Android in a totally new direction
which is I think very
important. That announcement that there are
a hundred thousand activations
going on, umm, every day with Android is only
gonna continue if we take Android
into every corner of the mobile portfolio.
And for hundreds of millions of
people in the world, they want devices like
this. So we wanna take all the
power and functionality of Android and make
it accessible and what we've done
with these two new products is we've created
a one-handed touch which, you know,
we consider to be very compact, very clever,
got a lot of interesting features
with a unique four corners UI. But there's
an important statement here. We
haven't fragmented the platform to do this.
We've made it so that your
applications are gonna run on this and we've
got developer guidelines and tools
on our developer site, developer.sonyericsson.com,
to help you bring your
products to these kinds of devices which are,
I think, really, really going to
help Android succeed in the long run while
keeping it a unified platform so that
all of your creations can run across those
products. That's basically what I
have to say.
>>Eric: Thank you, Bill. Great. Well, it's
great to be here as well. Again, my
name is Ciaran Rochford, I'm the director
of Android at Samsung San Jose office.
So it's great to be here at Google I/O this
week and get a chance to meet some
active Android developers. I've met a lot
of people in the pod and had a lot of
hard questions already so hopefully this is
more of a fireside than a grilling
today but I'm prepared. Umm, so one thing
that happened to me recently that I
wanted to share before I went to my main comments
and that is, my mother-in-law
asked me a question. She said, "Ciaran, what
are you working on?" And I
decided to pull out Android handset and actually
show her the handset. I went
to multitasking and multiple home screens,
and how network location finders work
and it all sounded great to me. I was very
interested but I could tell when I
looked at my mother-in-law, she wasn't, and,
umm, I could also tell she was kind
of thinking about how did my daughter end
up with a guy like this?
[laughter]
>>Ciaran: So luckily for me, though, when
I showed her some of the apps created
by you, the community, in relation to news,
stock, weather, entertainment, she
started to understand why this is important
and augmented reality is also
something she really enjoyed. So, again, this
really reemphasized to me that
the Android development community is at the
heart of Android and actually looks
like my mother-in-law's heart now as well
so I've got two bonuses there. So I
have two main points I wanna cover. The first
is Samsung's commitment to
Android. I'm happy to say, as the second largest
manufacturer in the world that
a large portion of our smartphones this year
will be based in Android. I think
it's clear to see that Android has moved from
an early-adapter platform to the
mainstream and with that will come a lot of
opportunities for increased
application download and sales. This will
also bring new challenges to the
areas of device compatibility and developer
support. I'm happy so say Samsung
is actively working on these areas already.
And speaking of handsets, I would
like to speak a little bit about our new Galexy
S handset, which is available
for view at our pod. This device has Samsung's
new super analogue display which
is WVJ in resolution, it also has a very thin
form factor and saves power. The
Galexy S also comes with 16 gigabytes of external
storage, a one gigahertz CPU
and both front and rear facing cameras. And
like my colleague here, Samsung's
also looking to make sure those are exposed
to you in terms of API in terms of
front-facing camera so you can take advantage
and build new apps that are very
creative. Again, drive that content to our
users. So the second thing I wanna
talk about is Samsung's commitment to the
Android developer community. I'm
happy to announce that we're going to be extending
our developer program, which
is called Samsung Mobile Innovator, to cover
Android this summer. It can be
found online at innovator.samsungmobile.com.
It'll have detailed technical
specifications on our handsets and also provide
direct support for developers.
We want to make sure that your apps look great
on our handsets so that's really
our goal.
[pause]
>>Ciaran: We know this is important because
we think Android developers are key
to making end consumers want to use Android
and so that's why we need to provide
this support. So to close, Samsung's one of
the original OHA members is very
excited about the growth and possibilities
Android offers and we look forward to
working with you and the rest of the ecosystem
to make sure it evolves and
grows. Thank you very much.
>>Eric: Thank you.
>>Joon: Should I stand or, uh –
>>Eric: Anything. You can dance if you want.
>>Joon: Certainly I'm not bad -- a good dance
so I'll just stand. First of all,
thank you very much for hosting this wonderful
event. I'm sure that everyone
here is benefiting in a lot of great technology
from Google not only from
Android respect but from all over technology
arena. My name is Joon Kang, I'm
leading the Android product development in
San Jose office in LG Electronics.
As you know, we are working very closely with
Google not only for Android but
also lot of different consumer devices such
as, you know, netbook, and TVs, and
even the home networking system and we are
also looking for as a partnership
getting into the emerging marketplaces where
our LG brand is so strong. So
coming back to Android now, we launched Optimus
-- I'm not sure how many people
that were aware of it. We launched the product
in Europe and globally last
month as well as the Optimus Q, one of the
series of the Optimus product, in
Korea as well. And, uh, I guess everyone is
showing their own device so I guess
I should do the same. This is Verizon Ally.
This is a GD product [inaudible] experience
device
that we work very hard, very closely with
Google for many months and one thing
I'm really proud of this product is the -- I
can confidently say that it is
world's best keyboard ever designed helped
through the Google engine. Thanks
Google again. So the reason that we are investing
heavily on the Android is
very simple. It's very rationalized. Number
one of course is it's free. Free
and yet it's the best. You know, free is a
very strong word; second thing,
Optimus, where the developer like you and
myself can realize the, you know,
creative thought into the reality; and third
thing is obviously the very healthy
ecosystem behind it. I'm very, you know, very
excited that, you know, wherever
I see them going into Android market it's
just the number of application coming
in I don't know how many on a daily basis
but I heard that the quarterly growth
rate, the number of application is over 70
percent, which is phenomenal. So
without further adieu, we at LG is very much
committed and convinced that
Android is the chosen one to be succeeding
on the leading the technology more
diverse places. So we are ready to contribute
to the, you know, new
technologies such as the dual core, dual display,
you know, and HTE support as
well as the LTE. In terms of the LTE, long
term evolution, we are the first in
company that will deliver the product -- deliver
the technology, as well as the
number one, the world's best technology provider
in displays. And the last
thing I wanna touch a little bit on our -- our
-- our endeavor to reach out to
developers worldwide. We have the web site
called developer.lgmobile.com where
you can connected to the, you know, all the
developer worldwide as well as you
can submit or suggest any constructive suggestion,
idea, where we can more
innovative, you know, and motivate and deliver
the better and, you know,
creative product into the consumer's spaces.
Thank you.
>>Eric: Thank you, Joon.
>>Lori: Hi, I'm Lori Fraleigh and I'm the
Director of the Developer Platform
Tools and Technical Services Team at Motorola
and Motorola decided quite a while
ago to base a huge percentage of its phone
portfolio on Android. Android to us
is the perfect mobile operating system for
us to grow our -- our future on.
It's open, it's well-architected to grow and
evolve over time, and it allows us
to spend our time innovating on top of it
and to bring consumers and developers
cool and unique features on which they can
build applications and experiences to
wow the world. And we don't have to invest
in re-architecting a mobile
operating system from scratch. We get everything
we need from Android so we're
very excited about that. We've launched more
than ten different distinct
devices in over a hundred different, umm,
regions, distributors, retail markets,
and carriers around the world. You know, we've
extended our Android portfolio
all around the world and we're very excited
by what is out there. We're getting
rave reviews on a number of our different
products and the one thing I've seen
standing in the sandbox this week is everyone
likes a different product.
Someone'll come up and say, "Wow, this is
the greatest keyboard. This has the
best slider experience." Someone else thinks
a different phone is better and
that's gonna be the same way with all the
different applications you create.
You're creating applications that are just
gonna wow many different segments of
the market whether it's a productivity application,
a game, a multimedia
application, you're creating different app
experiences that are just gonna wow
consumers out there and drive adoption of
your applications. Motorola has a
very long history of working with developers
and I'm part of the MOTODEV
Developer Network that engages with people
like you every day. We take what all
the great resources that Google's created
for you to enable you to create
Android applications and provide you with
the additional resources you need to
understand how to make your applications work
well on our devices. Whether it's
talking about unique features on our handsets
and how to create one application
that works across the entire array of Android,
uh, devices yet when it's running
on our application takes advantage of a unique
feature -- so there's know
fragmentation, you've got one binary working
everywhere -- we've got resources
for that; we have community based discussion
boards where you can ask your
questions about how to develop for our app
-- for our handsets; and then we go
around the world evangelizing Android to developers
in all locations of the
world. We did our first Android developer
summit in San Diego last fall at
CTIA. We went to Beijing in January and we
just competed -- completed a
two-week tour of Latin America speaking to
Android developers in Mexico City,
Buenos Aires, and Sao Paulo, Brazil, and I
can tell you that what you see here
for Android enthusiasm in the U.S. is existent
in all markets of the world.
Everywhere we go, people are excited about
creating applications for Android
devices, they're excited about the power of
the platform and they're constantly
coming up with things that amaze us. We've
talked to developers all the time
but we constantly see new ideas for applications
and we encourage you to be in a
innovative and work on all sorts of neat ways
to bring your applications to
market. It's us doing cool hardware features,
cool software features that
enable cool applications from you, it's the
community that's what's driving the
growth and adoption of Android and we're really
excited to be a part of that.
>>Eric: Thank you. So, umm, the next part
is we're going to open up the floor to
questions. You can either come up to the mic
-- one of the two mics in the
aisle to ask questions or you can enter it
in the Wave, with the URL, and, umm,
looks like we have –
>>audience member: First question to Samsung.
We grad to hear that you guys are
committed to Android. Great. What about Bada?
Is it competition? How do we
see that long term?
>>Ciaran: Thank you for
that question. So, umm, I think the one thing
we try to
do at Samsung is make sure we have choices
for our customers whether it be
carriers or the end user and Android's a great
platform and we're making a huge
investment on that platform and shipping an
enormous number of devices with that
platform. But in certain geographical locations,
or with certain carriers, or
certain geos around the world, it isn't just
appropriate. We wanna make sure
everyone has a smartphone and that allows
us to do that as a secondary solution.
The thing I'd say is, you know, there's a
very large domain. Bada is built on
Samsung's own existing platform which we've
had for a long time and will be
exposing APIs as well. But I don't think they're
in conflict.
>>Eric: Okay. Gentleman on the left.
>>audience member: Is it -- okay. Umm, so
first I would like to thank you all for
coming to interface with us developers. So
I have two questions and they can be
answered by any of you. The first question
is, on the iPhone platform, umm,
there is certainly a large segment of iPhone
users who the developers can, umm,
market their apps for but there's an even
bigger segment and that is for iPod
Touch users who have a device that is less
expensive and doesn't have a cell
phone radio and so far we haven't seen anything
like that for Android where it
is a small form factor like what we have,
umm, that fits in the pocket but is
less expensive and doesn't have a cell radio
and want to, uh, get your thoughts
on that, whether or not, umm, you four manufacturers
will be considering that.
And my second question is, uh, currently in
the release products we have almost
two or three classes of devices where some
are Google experienced and some are
customized UIs and some might even be something
else, might not even be
recognizably Android. And right now for our
consumers going to the store to buy
a product, they might not necessarily know
that a product is running Android and
will run my application. So I wanna get your
thoughts on how, umm, on the
marketing side, we can message better to the
end users that this is indeed
Android product and will run applications
for the Android ecosystem. Thank you.
[pause]
>>Bill: Do you wanna take that?
>>Lori: Sure. Umm, I guess to address your
first question, you know, I can't
comment on any future products but we're always
looking to innovate in terms of
form factors and different market segments.
So I think as you saw when Android
first started it was going after the higher
end smartphone market and you've
started to see it come down into some of the
lower tiers, uh, in terms of
handsets that are coming out from the different
manufacturers. So I think as
you see the years go on and as we move from
2010 into 2011, you'll see Android
on a wider variety of phones in the market.
Umm, I'm gonna let some other
people comment further. In terms of marketing,
you know, we do a lot of work
with our carrier customers in terms of how
they wanna market the device and so
it's definitely gonna vary a little bit on
a per customer basis but we are doing
a lot more to evangelize the applications
that are available for the phones.
Umm, and again that depends very much on a
market demographic of a particular
phone. Is this a high-end multimedia phone
you're gonna see more emphasis on
the multimedia apps. If it's -- is it going
after the teens, you might see more
emphasis on social networking and games. And
so we do this in partnership with
the carrier or the retail operator, depending
on the market segment of the
phone.
>>Bill: Yeah. I would agree with Lori that
it does depend -- the way that the
Android flavor of a particular product that
we make is marketed does really
obviously varied by geography and by customer.
But there is an old kind of
saying in our business that the end user doesn't
care what platform it is but I
think that that's changing, actually, and
I think the strong reflection of our
conversations with our customers, our operator
customers is that, in fact,
Android is a great way to -- to help to make
-- to sell a device. So I see -- I
see it, uh, really, really becoming an important
part of the identity of a lot
of our products and I think the people -- the
carriers that'll be carrying them
see the Android brand as an important way
because, you know, I mean, that --
your applications and the extensibility of
the Open Platform are what are gonna
continue to sell those products. So I think
it's -- it's gonna be a big deal.
>>Joon: Okay. The first question is the, you
know, the LG Electric has a variety
of the -- I would say the first spectrum of
the consumer device. We have
definite plan to utilize the benefit Android
operating system or market a lot of
different consumer device. However, the point
being is that you mention the
iPhone like device probably we need to, uh,
if you have some constructive idea,
let's talk, you know, afterward. Second question
is, uh, you know, we ultimate
deliver the product in the consumer and the
consumers is the carriers. Carriers
with different need and customizing requirement
because they feel like they know
how to address consumer's need on their specific
market. For instance, if you
look at China, I mean the, you know, the legality
matter, we can't really
utilize the greatest, you know, Google mobile
service on that vision. So I'm
sure that carriers and, you know, different
-- in marketing, they utilize
different, you know, different application
service to better address the
consumer's needs. So we are not trying to
put too much in a different way of
the Android but, I don't know, for certain,
marketing certain, the reason that
we have to, you know, respect whatever is
the market constraint. Okay?
>>Ciaran: Yeah. Just to add to that, I think
Android does offer a lot in the way
of convergence as well with all these different
devices running very similar on
a different operating system and obviously
as a large manufacturer like Samsung
covers a variety of different product portfolios,
we see that as an opportunity.
The other thing I'd say to the second part
is, much as my colleague said here,
is that we need to inform the channel and
make sure people are aware when people
are being sold handsets that the messaging
is correct. I think we are actively
working on that.
>>Eric: Yeah. I think it's the one last thing
to add is that obviously we've
been working very closely with handset developer
partners and also carriers
around the world and the consistent theme
we're hearing is that, especially on
the carrier side, that there is clear understanding
that application is
important and we're working very closely with
them number one to make sure that
Android application is on these devices so
that the user can get to the
applications that you guys are building, and
second is that in many cases a lot
of these marketing campaign actually center
around applications. And so, umm,
you know, what are all these carriers looking
for? Are they looking for
compelling, awesome application to help them
sell more devices? So the more we
can build these great applications to help
differentiate what -- how Android
devices are better than some of the other
devices, the more eager many of these
carriers and many of these partners here on
stage will be willing to, you know,
invest to kinda -- to leverage to help sell
devices. So, umm, let me take a
question from -- from the Wave and I actually
saw a few questions along the same
theme and the theme is, we're developers.
We really would like to have root
access to the device so that we can really
accelerate and do interesting things.
Let me throw it to the panel and see what
you guys think about that.
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Joon: I think the earlier, you know, provide
kind of the access to developer
but I think that's why I think last, you know,
trained developer made a, I
guess, not a good image for our devices. So
I guess the -- that the message I'm
trying to, you know, deliver here is that
we are very much open to -- to, you
know, open up to the, you know, development,
you know, platform to the developer
world. But, however, we'd like to set up some
sort of, like, a protocol. Like,
whoever sign up, and register, and certify
developer who can get our, you know,
developer image so on and so forth.
>>Ciaran: Yeah. Just to add to that, I think,
umm, you know, most people don't
need access to the bootloader. If you're a
regular developer, which a majority
of developers are, as developing apps, you
don't need bootloaders. If you're
trying to hack a kernel or something that's
a different story but that's a very
small percentage of the people in general
and maybe that can be addressed in a
different way. We are trying to make sure
that the regular app developers are
taken care of and can use regular devices
for the development.
>>Bill: Yeah. I mean, the other thing, obviously,
most of you guys are
interested in making applications and there
are contributors to the overall
Android platform, you know, that are doing
system software. That's a different
category. Our view is, you know, you take
a really well-architected platform
like Android and there's a lot of stuff you
can do with applications in our
sandbox we're showing off a bunch on this
little mini phone where we basically
came up with a zooming capability to do one-handed
zooming to avoid this need
for pinch -- pinching on a small screen and
all done entirely in application
code and we're sharing the sample code that
you can use it in your applications
as well. So I think good architecture makes
it possible for a lot of your
creativity to come alive with the applications
without access to all the rest of
the bottom of the platform.
>>Eric: Okay. Really quick question to the
right.
>>audience member: I just wanted to add to
that. Umm, yeah. So you say you don't allow
people root access because it kinda messes
with that, uh, what? The environment
that developers are building the platform
for but wouldn't you, like, assume
that whoever's, like, rooting their device
if you were to open it up would know
that there are consequences that applications
might not run how they expected?
And, uh, my actual question was, do you guys
have any plans to do any, like,
serial device kind of like external accessories?
I know that I've seen it with,
uh -- like, a few devices already have, like,
serial interfaces but they're
disabled in the kernel. But I was curious
if, like, on the iPhone, anyway,
there's GPS accessories or if, like, you're
in a building GPS doesn't really
work so the people make, like, external antennas
that the app can talk to and,
uh, there's, like, stereo integration and
I'm just curious if you guys are
planning to add that to any of your devices.
>>Eric: Accessories.
>>Lori: So Motorola has a long history of
doing accessories for our devices
through our companion products group. Umm,
in terms of a lot of specific tight
integrations we unfortunately haven't, you
know, announced a lot that we can
talk about yet but it's something that Motorola
does invest a lot in.
[pause]
>>Bill: Same. Accessories are a great business,
you know. Uh, traditionally
Sony Ericsson's made fantastic margins on
accessories so I'm sure we're very
interested in it.
>>audience member: I mean more from, like,
a developer's standpoint.
>>Bill: Yeah.
>>audience member: Like, if I was gonna make
an app that had an accessory that would
complement it versus just using pre-made accessories
from the carrier. Do you
guys plan to, like, uh, I guess move in that
direction?
>>Bill: Yeah. We just have to consider it
on a case-by-case basis. We
definitely are looking at it.
>>Eric: Yeah. And the platform itself is,
uh, for example, support USB, we, for
example, over in the sandbox we have square
using audio jack as an accessory to
swipe credit card. So there's actually many
ways with a Bluetooth to connect
with a device and build accessories. So we're
starting to see more and more of
this interesting, innovative accessories that
people are building through the
standard APIs, the standard way of connecting
with many Android devices that all
these guys are building. Question to the left?
>>audience member: Uh, yes. I wanted to obviously
say thank you again for all you guys
coming out and by all means not to attack
you at all, but purely --
[laughter]
>>audience member: That's an open-ended statement.
>>Eric: I'm looking for a shield.
>>audience member: Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm curious
to find out if any -- if there's
any – yeah.
[laughter]
>>audience member: Putting on the raincoats
now. Is the any future talk about any type
of longevity to the battery life of these
devices? Umm, through development,
I've experienced some problems with the longevity
of the batteries, most of them
only lasting about a half a day through general
use or my extraneous use. Is
there any plans to maybe roll out a battery
that lasts three to four days?
Something with a solar connection to it or
something that we can actually plan
on taking it for the weekend and not coming
back to it?
[pause]
>>Ciaran: Well, obviously battery life is
very important and we take it very
seriously. I will say, just as my own pitch
here, the Galexy S has 20 percent
better battery life in terms of its monitor
power requirements than the previous
one because of the super AMOLED display. So
we are very actively working on
that. And just a final pitch here, this is
not only 20 percent better battery
saving but actually 20 percent brighter as
well so you get the best of both
worlds. And I think like all the manufacturers
we're measuring that and
thinking of ways of trying to improve.
>>Joon: Same here. I mean, the first thing
recommendation for you is to change
your auto synchronization period so you can
get a lot better life.
>>audience member: I have 13 e-mails.
[laughter]
>>Joon: All right. Battery's one of the, uh,
major technology investment we are
putting on. We notice that especially smartphone
and even in a smartphone get
connect to the whole different customer device
like the TVs and, uh, all
different device. So things get, you know,
is not more attention to it and
there is also different technology now that,
you know, solars through the
charging technology as you all coming in.
So that is something area that we're
still investing on.
[pause]
>>Lori: Umm, Motorola has a unique social
networking service called MOTOBLUR on
some of our handsets and what this does is
rather than having five or ten
different apps that are constantly pulling
the network at different intervals
and starting the data connection pull and
shutting down, it batches the updates
into Push updates. And so this is something
that we have done through the
experiences we create for consumers to optimize
the battery life. And so we're
taking these experiences that we've created
for our own software and trying to
figure out how we can enable developers to
take advantage to this as well to
improve the overall experience for the consumer
on the handset.
[pause]
>>Eric: Yeah. I think the last thing to add,
too, is it really is a partnership
with all of you, too, in terms of how you
build your application, how often you
hit the network, how often you, you know,
put something on the screen. All of
these have a huge impact. I mean, I can't
tell you how many times I've -- my
relatives are using Android phone not really
understand what's happening under
the hood and they don't understand why the
battery's draining while meanwhile
they're getting all the e-mails in the back.
And so I think there are a lot of
things that, you know, all of you can do to,
you know, to help, you know, kind
of reduce the amount of battery -- the amount
of power you're using on each of
these devices.
>>audience member: Great. Thank you very much.
>>Eric: So, up, let me kinda go to the Wave.
Umm, so I also saw a few questions
about updates. Uh, obviously we just announce
Android 2.2 so I think everybody
have -- big question is that, you know, where
are each one of your plan in terms
of updating the devices that, you know, developers
may have to, you know, the
next version -- the next release?
[pause]
>>Lori: So we will be pushing out Android
2.2 to the Droid over the next few
months. Uh, we're working on the exact details
of the schedule in conjunction
with Google as well. It's announced, it's
not fully out in Open Source yet as
well as with Verizon in terms of how to time
that update. And we actually have
a public web site where we post information
about when we expect to roll
software updates out to our various phones
in different regions in the world and
it's actually a pretty complex problem because
there's not just -- you know, we
have more than one phone. Umm, on top of Android
we build a lot of different
experiences. There's carrier software, there's
pre-loaded applications, and
unfortunately at times it's a little bit more
complicated process that some
would like in terms of rolling out updates
and so it's something that we do in
conjunction with Google and our carrier partners
in terms of getting those
updates out to everyone. And so we do publish
that information for developers
and consumers to be aware of.
>>Joon: I'm the same -- same scenario. I'm
the same situation that other people
have for a Google device that we let us huge
support from Google from -- for a
device that are not a Google device we have,
you know, web interface that
reaching out to the every single device automatically
over the web. However,
you know, to identify which carriers, you
know, which version, you know, in our
countries is a little bit tricky. But, however,
we do have infrastructure and
we can automatically consumer that the device
can automatically global the web.
[pause]
>>Ciaran: Yeah. So, umm, in terms of Samsung
obviously because we are reaching a
lot of different markets there's different
strategies. But generally Samsung's
always trying to make sure that the handsets
are updatable. For those working
with carriers obviously we have to work with
the carrier through those channels
but for the open market I would advise everyone
to download the new SGH program,
which is Samsung's sync program, with your
PC and, uh, you can find a link on
that at innovator.samsungmobile.com and that'll
have the latest bills available
for your -- for your handset and there's new
updates available depending on your
geo, etc. But it is a complex problem and
we are definitely very focused on it.
>>Bill: Yeah. So, uh, as with my colleagues
here, we're also going to be
updating our devices during 2010. We've got
some announcements on that. That's
also on our developer site. You can, umm,
find out the schedule for that as we
work it out with Google. Umm, we are in many,
many markets as well, obviously
globally and there's so many -- it's just
one of the hardest things to do when
it comes to continually making a product that
satisfies a wide variety of users.
But, umm, but we're definitely committed to
staying current. It's the -- it's
the -- it's really the only way that, up,
that the innovations that are
introduced in a very aggressive way into Android
can, you know, become more
stable and then expose to developers and you
can take advantage of all that
stuff. So you're definitely gonna see us keeping
to that schedule.
>>Eric: Thank you, Bill. Question to your
right.
>>audience member: Yeah. I just wanna say
thanks, guys, for giving us the time today
to
talk to us. Umm, fragmentation is one of the
words -- I wanna touch on that now
but it's one of the words that keeps getting
thrown around all the time and I
think partly that's due to, umm, Google. You
know, they're constantly now this
month updating their list of new versions
and as developers and consumers I
guess my question is mainly at the gentleman
from Samsung. Umm, you guys -- I
know you guys are pretty focused on TouchWiz
right now but, umm, the moment I
think -- if I'm not mistaken was one of the
first devices in the U.S. market to
get 2.1 before a lot of the other devices
and I think, uh -- hope that's because
it's a stock Android device. And my main question
is, is Samsung committed to
also coming out with stock Android devices
to us? Most of us here
in the room
are definitely what's considered power users.
Umm, are you guys committed to
coming out with more stock Android phones
that we hope will get updated to the
newest version before the rest?
>>Ciaran: Thank you. So that's, uh, that's
really good feedback and it's part of
the reason we come to these developer forums
is to get feedback and to hear what
you're looking for as well. Umm, you know,
we are, as I said -- as you
mentioned, updating our handsets in the field
and we continue to do that.
Specifically around TouchWiz, we are evolving
that. Exactly what it's
configuration is, is still under development
but I really do appreciate your
feedback.
>>Eric: Okay. Next person on the left.
>>audience member: Actually, my question is
related to the previous question. It's also
like I have maybe comments as well. For instance,
Motorola has a phone which
has two screens, LG has an Android phone,
has a longest screen and Samsung has a
phone has two cameras. All these are great
add-on to the phone. However, it
created problems for the developers to develop
cross plat -- cross handsets
Android applications. What other efforts has
been taken to improve to insure
the accountability of Android applications
cross different manufacturers?
Actually, my second question is that, uh,
there are three companies on the panel
list has alternative platforms. There is the
opinion that, uh, after other
lower end manufacturers can be able to produce
Android-based smartphones, you
know, September 6 marks our two years, there
will be no space for alternative --
for other operating systems on a lower end
site. What's your comments on that
one? Thank you.
[pause]
>>Lori: So I'll comment mostly on your -- your
first question. You know, every
single device Motorola has shipped is compliant
with the Android platform. It's
passed all the required tests from Google
to insure compliance. If you look at
some of the unique features we've created,
if you look at the Motorola Backflip,
it has the unique navigation device on the
back of the device called the
Backtrack. It is possible, despite the fact
that this is completely unique to
Motorola, the write an application, a single
binary, that will work across all
the Android devices yet when running on the
Motorola device takes advantage of
the Backtrack all within a single binary.
So to that extent, when we do come
out with innovations, we ensure they're compliant,
we ensure that they don't
create fragmentation, and then we publish
information to developers on how to
take advantage of it and how to properly code
your application to insure that
consumers have the best experience.
[pause]
>>Joon: Same here in the LG Electronic. Every
Android product we released to
the market under the Google CTS, Compliance
Testing Suite, and we get
certification from Google before the product
get launched. So I don't think we
are making, you know, any fragmentation here.
On top of that, whenever I make a
extension we submit it back to the, you know,
the Open Source community for
getting back to the -- to nurture the Android
developer network.
>>Ciaran: Yeah. I think also very similarly,
we also passed CTS and it's now the
compatibility documents online but I think
you can actually go and read and see
for yourselves exactly why that the test criteria
and the requirements to each
document is now public. So I think it's at
developer.android. --
>>Eric: Sourceandroid.com.
>>Ciaran: Sourceandroid.com. So, uh, please
check that out. You can sort of
sound what we're working on in terms of that.
And the thing I'd say is we also
have extensions like front-facing camera and
we will make those out as pure
add-ons and as someone else mentioned, you
can write an application that's
generic. It can specialize it behavior or
run time if it finds that extra
functionality like from facing cameras available
or do something else if it's not.
So that really is up to the developer.
[pause]
>>Bill: Yeah. I mean, there's a reason that
Android is growing so fast and one
of the reasons that there are a variety of
products that are made out of it and
some of them are gonna be, you know, have
front-facing cameras, and some won't,
and some will be, you know, very expensive
and some will be very affordable. So
that's part of the cause of success but as
with everybody else, we -- everything
is fully compatible. Umm, and we, you know,
Sony Ericsson, are also
contributing back a lot of what we do. You
can go to check out a lot of
what they contributions are and it's a dialogue.
Technology's always a dialogue
and so if there's a direction that we think
the products need to go and the
platform needs to support, we found a very
receptive, uh, ear in Google for how
to take that platform so it can generally
support something that we may add to
make a particular product really shine.
>>Eric: Thank you. I think the only thing
-- I just wanna make sure you guys
don't miss it that we -- please go to source.android.com.
We've, uh, published
some web pages around compatibility and on
there we have a compatibility
definition document and also the compatibility
test Suite. So now all of you
can see, you know, the -- in terms of the
specifications and the test reads that
all of these partners are building the headset
against. They kinda get a better
sense of how -- where we're doing, what kind
of tools we put in place to make
sure these handsets are indeed compatible.
I see we're stacking up here. So
quick question. All right.
>>audience member: My question is directed
mostly at -- to the Motorola. There's been
a
couple news articles recently that you guys
dropped the Google network location
provider and they were Skyhook. Could you
give us some kinda history there or
what was the reasoning and has that created
any friction with Google as far as
creating Google-branded devices?
>>Lori: Sure. So I think some of the write-ups
of the Skyhook press release were
actually miswrite-ups. We haven't dropped
the Google network location provider
from the handsets. We have chosen to try to
integrate Skyhook's technology
alongside of it to provide a variety of choice
for consumers and developers in
terms of how they can get network location
information, umm, 'cause sometimes
you're in a location where you might not be
able to get accuracy from one type
of device -- or one type of provider and so
there's different ways of doing it
but we're not dropping it and we're not replacing
it. Some of the initial
write-ups were wrong and so we worked with
Google and with Skyhook to get those
corrected.
>>audience member: Thank you.
>>Eric: Okay. Question on the left.
>>audience member: Hello, guys. My name is
Sarcon. I from where, I used to be where
you locate one of your pre-load partners.
First of all, thank you for coming
and, umm, for cherishing Android. Uh, my question
is, umm, about the same
thing, fragmentation. Umm, we deal with a
lot of carriers and, Android
versions, different OEMs, UIs, and then permutation
of all we create this
fragmentation. Uh, do you guys work together,
uh, among OEMs?
>>Eric: We never talk. I never talk to them.
[laughter]
>>audience member: And it's -- it's -- it
takes a long time for a device -- why does
it
take so long for a device to receive upgrade
from 1.5 to 2.1, like Hero? I know
HTC's not out there but, umm, do you guys
work together to, I don't know, iron
this out?
[pause]
>>Lori: Lucky me, I'm still holding the mic.
>>Eric: [laughter]
>>Eric: We can fight you for it.
>>Lori: So the length of time to do an upgrade
depends on a variety of things.
Umm, first, the version of Android has to
fully reach Open Source. You know,
the day Google releases it, the source -- or
talks about it, the source code's
not out there and that's not always I think
immediately known to all the
consumers and developers. So the source code
has to hit the Open Source market,
the Compatibility Test Suite has to be fully
published, we have to get our
software integrated and tested on top of it
and depending on the handset, you
know, you've heard discussions of stock Android
versus more highly
differentiated. You know, our phones that
have MOTOBLUR are highly
differentiated and so the integration and
testing of that software on top of a
new version of Android, umm, takes more time.
The integration and testing of a
new version of Android on a different hardware
platform then would have been the
feature device for that version of Android
takes more time. The integration of
testing of pre-load application of carrier-specific
requirements takes more
time. And then there is the whole carrier
lab cycle and test cycle that takes a
lot of time. And it's really hard to explain
all of that to the consumer, to
the developer. Umm, you know, we'd like it
to be faster. We're constantly
working to improve our ability to do this.
Umm, and we try and get information
out to developers, you know, as readily as
we can. So it's something we're
trying to work on and we know -- we know it's
hard.
[pause]
>>Joon: Same sequence and, uh, couple thing
probably is the chipset has to also
be upgraded to the latest version as well
as when you're building umm, you know,
the newer -- newer version of the Android
for the consumers that are out there,
you always has to evaluate are the application
being customized for certain
carriers, certain languages, certain region,
blah, blah, blah because otherwise
you cannot really ship the up-to-date version
to America two months after and
then, for instance, like somewhere else in
another countries like six months
after. You have to much know same speed, addressing
the number of different
version simultaneously. That's why it's taking
a little while but we are
trying -- absolutely trying to improve the
speed of the upgrading process.
[pause]
>>Ciaran: I don't -- I don't really have anything
to add. Samsung's very
committed to making sure we can upgrade but
it is a complicated process, as my
colleagues had mentioned.
>>Bill: Umm, the only thing I would say is,
you know, you're a pre-load partner,
I guess, so you benefit from your stuff working
really fantastically with some
of our devices and you want that to continue
to happen when we upgrade to the
next version of Android. So as Lori said,
there's layers of testing that stuff.
We have to test it, our operator partners
have to test it, and man I wish it
were faster. One thing I wanted to add in
case anybody mentions it, is
something about the Android Market. When you
do, umm, write your apps and put
them in the Android Market, you set max and
min for versions of Android and we
were talking about this before but if you
want your stuff to appear like some of
the companies that we've worked with, umm,
their stuff runs great on our
products but it -- when -- when an upgrade
can happen, sometimes because of the
way they've uploaded it to the Android Market,
it can be momentarily not visible
as downloading to our handsets. So make sure
when you put that manifest
together when you upload stuff that you're
following the upload path. You know,
you're following the upgrade path, excuse
me, to make your products be able to
continue to be visible to all of our products.
>>Eric: Yeah. Let me just clair -- make sure
everybody understands that. What
we've done with between Android platform Android
Market is give developers the
flexibility when they upload the application
to declare what version Android OS
they want the application should be visible
to. Some developers decide may want
to leave it open so they will say my application
will work on Android 1.5 and
anything beyond that. And we've seen a lot
of case many app just works,
developer never seen these new devices and
the app just works out of the box.
In some cases, some developers are a little
more conservative, for good reasons.
They decide I want my application only to
work on 1.5 and 1.6 and when that
happens, when the user upgrade the device
to let's say 2.1 or 2.2, then
obviously that device is no longer visible
to that application. So again what
we're trying to do is give you more tools
so you have more choices in how you
wanna structure your business, how you want
to distribute your application, and
so just keep that in mind and then, you know,
it's completely up to you on how
you want to structure things.
>>audience member: Thanks.
>>Eric: Question on the right.
>>audience member: Thank you. Umm, my question
has to do with, uh, customization of
settings and software applications for various
operators and I'd be interested
in hearing from all of you, maybe even a question
for Google but I guess the
lady from Motorola was talking about launching
phone -- launching products to
multiple operators, multiple regions. Can
you provide any guidance or
guidelines for how to customize your application
or customize the settings to
meet the particular needs of an operator?
[pause]
>>Eric: Can you give an example? What do you
mean by, like, a setting?
>>audience member: A really simple one would
be browser bookmarks. If you had, you
know, one -- three or four operators within
a single region and you wanted to be
able to -- to customize those bookmarks for
-- for each operator.
[pause]
>>Lori: So I'm not aware of specific customizations
we do in that area although
it's entirely possible that we do. Umm, if
you wanna, you know, talk more in
depth I'd be happy to talk with you afterwards.
I'm just not aware of specific
things. You know, in terms of handling operator
requirements, you know, to the
extent that they ask us to customize something
that they feel is a strong
requirement as long as it doesn't violate
the compatibility document and the
device still passes CTS, if it's something
that they feel is important to them
and, you know, we come to an agreement, then
we make that customization for
them. Umm, in terms of something specific
I'd be happy to talk with you more to
understand the details and comment on a particular
device.
>>Eric: Okay. One recommendation would be,
umm, use the network and what I mean
by that is you can have your application on
the device determine what region
it's running in, umm, and then from there
you can potentially download
whatever's needed for that particular device.
And so there are ways for you to
do late binding and have the customer information
come in later in the device,
not as part of the initial download. That's
probably the best way for you to
have more flexibility in how you build your
application.
>>Eric: Okay. Thank you.
>>audience member: Hi. My question would be
about sun cells. Accelerometers and
Compass has turned out no on Android but what
about new type of sensors? So
what I understood is that it's up to the OEM,
you know, to choose if they want a
new sensor or not and all those kinds of things
and the question would be, how
that made available to the developers? Because
each OEM will choose different
dates to have a new type or not and that means
you won't be turned out across
other platforms. So OEM will make API the
development and how development can
be sure that it will be the same depending
-- you know, it won't be dependent on
the platforms they use?
>>Eric: Actually, let me try to field this
one. Umm, a good example is
front-facing camera. That in itself is a sensor
and we've had a couple of
phones to come out have front-facing camera
and what we actually did is we let
you work with the OEMs who, uh, actually come
with the products and my
suggestion is how to structured API and is
what that does at least from an
instruction syntax perspective is somewhat
similar across different devices.
What that does also is puts it on our radar
so that way when we come out with
the next release of the OS, the way we're
gonna structure API will be roughly
the same -- the same way so that when you
want a migrate application to support,
let's say, the front-facing camera API in
the future we have that, that it will
be a very simple migration. And -- and the
challenge has always been, right, if
we wanna get a platform out there that work
across all devices, at the same time
leave it open for innovations we have to make
a possible innovations. And then
it's, you know, us working closely to make
sure that when these innovations come
out, especially on our side with we see multiple
OEMs and, you know, we talk to
them all the time and say, you know, this
is what's coming out of the pot and we
see a similar trend from multiple major manufacturers
then obviously we're going
to accelerate the development schedule to
support that, too.
>>audience member: So it means it's basically
driven from Google. So let's take an
example. Let's take Gyroscope for example.
People wants to integrate their
Gyroscopes that means that OEM are come to
you and say I'm planning to do that,
can you propose an API and then the OEM will
most likely use it, or --
>>Eric: I wouldn't go as far as to say they
come to us and say, can you propose
an API. The key thing about Open Platform
is that this gives everybody the
ability to innovate. What we try to do is
base on information that we get, to
try to see some trend; right? It doesn't make
sense for us to make an API for a
new sensor and require on all Android devices
when only one manufacturer wants
to do it. But with we see that multiple manufacturer
wants to do this, then
that gives us a good indication that this
is what's coming out of the pipe, we
beat the price point is now low enough that
it makes sense to integrate these
type of sensors. So it's the collaboration
of partnership at the same time
making sure that the core of the platform's
compatible across all devices while
giving OEMs and carriers the ability to innovate.
>>audience member: Okay. And second question
more like a dream, actually. Would it be
possible to have a peek upon what kind of
sensor are coming up and what's the
new things like the second camera which is
in some products but maybe next
generation? I mean, I will understand if you
say no, I don't want to disclose
that, but if you have anything.
[pause]
>>Eric: Okay. I guess you cannot comment--
[laughter]
>>Eric: Okay. Let me, uh, take a question
from the Wave. Umm, I think the gist
of this is, what about Flash? Any plan for
Flash supporting your products?
Anybody able to comment on that?
>>Ciaran: I'd like to say that, umm, Samsung
has worked closely with Adobe and
other products to support Flash and so, umm,
I think this will be an opportunity
for us to do so again in the future.
[pause]
>>Bill: So similarly, umm, you know, uh, Flash
is an important, uh, content type
in many of the markets where we're very strong
so we're definitely gonna be
there when the time is right.
[pause]
>>Joon: I think LG has same position. We are
working with Adobe as well.
>>Lori: Uh, we committed earlier this year
to bringing Flash to Droid when it was
ready for production. Umm, and so as Froyo
is getting pushed out to Droid, as
the Flash 10.1 moves out of beta and into
production you'll see that coming to
Droid. As far as some of our other handsets,
you know, watch for upcoming
details.
>>Eric: Great. Person on the right.
>>audience member: Umm, I work for a carrier
and as we talk to the various manufacturers
up there we see that there's sort of this
imaginary dividing line where there's
Google's commonality and everything is the
same up to a certain point and then after
that, a bunch of things get different. For
example, at the tethered updates
versus over-the-air updates, versus all these
other different ways. Or
application pre-loading process for carriers
is different across all of them.
Or like the other gentleman was saying, bookmarking
and stuff like that. Is
there any thought by Google or the OEMs to
get together and say, let's make some
standardization a little bit further on down
so that, you know, update processes
are common across all the manufacturers? Umm,
carrier pre-loads are common
across all the manufacturers, things like
that, so there's more
commonality to it? Thank you.
[pause]
>>Bill: One of the -- one of the variables
in those factors you just mentioned
are our carrier customers and how they wanna
do things. So some of our -- our
approaches are in fact driven by that and
whether it makes sense, you know, the
other way to look at it is I guess there could
be one common approach that most
of the network operators take with respect
to some of these things and maybe you
guys should get together.
[laughter]
>>Bill: But, umm, I totally see your -- your
-- you know, in general, like I said
earlier, technology's a conversation and the
conversation about commonality is
always going on with Google and even between
some of us I'm sure.
[pause]
>>Eric: Okay.
>>audience member: Uh, Android is an amazing
Open Source operating system. How soon
'til we get an Open Source mobile phone?
[applause]
>>audience member: There are 13 Open Source
hardware companies out there that have
revenues totaling over 50 million they are
on an upward trajectory.
>>Lori: So I think if you look at a mobile
phone from any one of the four of us
you'll find that it's made up of a number
of components. Some of it is Open
Source IP, some of it is our own IP, and some
of it is IP we license from many,
many different partners that are -- that we
embed into the handset whether it's,
umm, you know, chipset, something to accelerate
something on the chipset,
whether it's a multimedia codec, and it's
more than just us that would have to
come together to Open Source an entire mobile
phone. There are -- it's much
more than us and, you know, it's a lot of
people's IP-ing. So I think as time
goes on, more and more things start to become
Open Source and maybe someday we
get there but it's not something that's gonna
happen probably in the next year
or two.
[laughter]
>>Ciaran: I agree.
>>Eric: Okay. I think we have time for maybe
a couple more questions. Uh, I
wanna take one.
>>audience member: Uh, when I first came to
Android I was attracted by the Open Source
and being able to customize my phone how I
wanted to and that's why drives me to
be, you know, a root user and to be able to
modern my phone. As such, I made
applications to allow users to theme their
phones and I find it frustrating
that, you know, non-root users don't have
the ability to theme their phones or
customize their phones to specific tastes,
maybe to a football theme or a sport
theme. Do y'all have any thoughts on providing
theme support? I mean, it's as
simple as using a content provider. A lot
of y'all build desktop replacements
like HTP does with their sense. Do y'all have
any comments? Google and the
carriers.
>>Eric: So specific question is theme support?
>>audience member: Right.
>>Joon: We do certainly have a widget-based
approach so user can personalize
their, uh, you know, theme and the home menu
and other -- other places.
[pause]
>>Bill: Yeah. I mean, themes have actually
-- I think Sony Ericsson invented
themes on phones and we've, you know, been
-- it's been a -- it's been a really,
really important way for us -- for our products
to be sold and they're
actually -- there's a business in personalization
and themes. So, you know,
within the, you know, uh, constraints and
possibilities of Android, we're very
interested in personalization and we're gonna
be adding more capabilities in the
future. So I think it's one of the thing that
is people wanna do with their
mobile devices is self-expression.
>>Joon: If I can say just one more thing.
Not one more thing. I mean as I
mentioned earlier, we do have a developer
web site to, you know, respecting all
the greatest comment from everywhere. So just
join us and, uh, send us
constructive suggest, idea, or criticize ideas,
to, so we can be all learn and
improving the Android platform and the delivery
created innovative service and
product and quality to the consumer worldwide.
So, you know, go to the -- our
developer.lgmobile.com and, uh, feel free
to write up any suggestion you might
have.
>>Eric: Okay. One more question and probably
can only have one person answer
this since, uh, we're 30 seconds left.
[laughter]
>>audience member: I had a question about
the keyboard. A couple of you mentioned how
great your new keyboards were. Uh, my first
phone was the G1 and personally I
think it's the best keyboard that's ever been
on a phone. I think a lot of
other people think the same way. What's taken
so long to come out with this new
greatest keyboard or, you know, a keyboard
without a space bar between the V and
B, or, you know, keys that aren't mashed together?
Uh, we had such a great
example of what a wonderful keyboard should
look like. Why haven't we got --
why hasn't anybody been able to duplicate
that or even come close really?
[pause]
>>Lori: Keyboards are very, very subjective.
Like I said earlier, I've talked to
many people here at this show and they walk
up and everyone likes a different
phone, everyone likes a different keyboard.
Umm, and again I think it comes
back to where -- who is the target customer
for this phone? Is it a teen, which
is gonna have a lot tinier fingers than someone
in their 30s. Umm, what's the
target demographic? What does the carrier
wanna see? Every phone goes through
a lot of user trials before it ever comes
back and even once it's in production,
feedback comes back and that's incorporated
into future designs. So, you know,
while you may think the G1 keyboard's the
greatest keyboard in the world,
someone else is gonna think, you know, having
a phone with no keyboard's the
greatest experience and that's --
>>audience member: I can understand that.
>>Lori: And so it's really up to the target
-- the target market, umm, and where
that phone is going.
>>Joon: I just waned to suggest to you to
drop by LG's, you know, sandbox. I
mean, really, seriously.
>>audience member: I will. I wanna see it.
>>Joon: I mean, this is the -- in the old
configuration you may not notice but
this key's not equal -- it has H key has a
different variation of height and
space between each keys to make sure that
we deliver the best keyboard
experience. We work really hard with Google
for this particular keyboard
setting, and the layout, and even all different,
you know, key set.
>>audience member: Okay. Thank you.
>>Eric: Great. Well, thank you. I think we're
on borrowed time now so I wanted
to thank all of you being on the panel.
[Applause]
>>Eric: And even more questions, umm, all
these folks are -- we have five
stations out there from different device manufacturers
so you can go there and
ask -- ask away many more questions. Okay.
Thank you.